i
was the first governor in the country
that passed the build that bans critical
race theory uh and and the media kind of
calls it critical race theory but here's
all my bill said it just simply said
that in our school system
uh we're not gonna teach that one race
or one sex is superior to another race
or another sex that's all it says and i
don't know how you can argue huh
old school old school how can you argue
with that
do you sense we're divided sort of in an
irreparable fashion i mean when you talk
about freedom and capitalism and limited
government and all those things that
yeah that's happening in red states it
really is it seems to be strengthening
in certain states certainly the two
states that we're in but it's not
happening in blue states and it doesn't
seem like it's going to turn around in
blue states what do you think about that
tension going forward as the united
states of america
you know i mean that that's the
million-dollar question
you know you you look back to our
leaders like you know ronald reagan and
it felt like he could bring people
together and kind of talk about
capitalism and the exceptionalism of
america uh in a way that kind of brought
us together and revitalized our country
and so we hope that we can get back
there uh because i believe that the
majority of americans think like i do we
we believe in in uh and we believe in
god and i think you take god out of the
values and we believe in uh we were
found at our country on these biblical
values uh we believe in uh freedom of
religion uh that means we don't
discriminate against any religion but we
certainly don't discriminate it we can't
discriminate against the christian faith
either
and so i i think that most people
believe in family and and and capitalism
and and uh and you have to work hard and
let's create a level playing field for
everybody to go succeed and it's just
disappointing when some people think
that the answer is government handouts
and they think that the answer is
more government and more taxes
that's just you can look across history
you can look at other other countries
that have tried that model and and i
think that's failing and but i think
that i still believe that the majority
of americans think like we do so if we
say this in a in the correct way uh and
i believe that's the winning message
yeah i'm with you how have you guys done
when it comes to all of the woke stuff
keeping the the gender stuff and the the
critical race theory all of that out of
the schools or has it seeped in and and
what are you doing about it you know
again sometimes it tries to seep in what
i've done about it is i
was the first governor in the country
that passed the build that bans critical
race theory uh and and the media kind of
calls it critical race theory but here's
all my bill said it's it just simply
said that in our school system uh we're
not gonna teach that one race or one sex
is superior to another race or another
sex that's all it says and i don't know
how you can argue huh
old school old school how can you argue
with that let's teach our kids not
indoctrinate them and teach them that
they're inferior because of the color of
their skin or they're somehow
responsible for something that happened
100 years ago i'm not going to teach
that to a first grader this is that's
ridiculous
and so
i also signed the the save women and
sports bill which to us in oklahoma i
mean we don't know what's going on with
the rest of the country because for us
it's like everybody applauds me that
that we're gonna have we're gonna
protect women's sports and athletics and
girls are going to play in girls sports
and boys are going to play in boy sports
i'm not going to let a biological male
compete in high school against a a
female that's been training her whole
life where he has physical advantages on
the track or or in the swimming pool
against that girl and it's just it
doesn't make sense to us in oklahoma so
it's easy for me to sign these kind of
bills
is there any pushback on that stuff in
oklahoma you get anything i mean
you get some the whacked out folks but
uh it's a very small small minority here
yeah
what else is going on uh since you're
talking so much about business and that
really is your your background and
you've mentioned this sort of low you
know
less regulation and that sort of thing
what else is going on in in the business
world if someone's watching this in cali
right now and they're thinking about
getting out and i get emails every day
from cali people on the way out and i'm
usually selling them on florida but if
they want to stop before they get here
and see what's going on
you got to stop i mean listen florida's
second place compared to oklahoma okay
you might have a little bit of the ocean
but uh if you want to make money and you
want to be
and you want the quality of life
oklahoma's the right spot to be but
you know technology companies we're
going hard after i'm looking at where
the the research and development dollars
are headed where we just landed a huge
huge electric vehicle manufacturer we're
going after that supply chain around
electric vehicles we have more electric
vehicle charging stations per capita
than any other state level three
charging stations so we're leaning into
that stuff most people go well
oklahoma's just oil and gas simply not
true i mean we love our oil and gas and
we are we are making sure that we do our
part for our country on our oil and gas
side but we're also uh not naive to
where the r d dollars are headed they're
not in combustible engines anymore
they're in electric vehicles uh so we
are all in there uh we're going into
hydrogen we just we we are we're looking
at that transition and and what type of
other energy sources can we have and as
as as california's having rolling
blackouts we have the cheapest
electricity cost to the business uh in
the country
yeah it's nice to hear things are going
right sometimes right i mean so what are
your headaches then i mean what are what
are really the headaches you're giving
me a pretty rosy picture of a state and
you seem like things are pretty sensible
there and all that stuff you must have a
couple headaches well i've got a couple
teenage daughters so uh if you could
help me i've got six kids and uh
six kids
yeah my wife and i we've been married 24
years we have six children our oldest is
21 down to eight
so just like just like every every
business person or or or mom that's
having to work you have to balance uh
you know your your home life and raising
your kids and being a good husband and a
good father as well as your your day job
which my day job happens to be governor
of the state
so it's all it's always busy but uh it's
fun it's an honor of a lifetime to serve
your state where your your grandparents
grew up and i pinched myself thinking
about my granddad who had an eighth
grade education he was a dairy farmer in
skytock oklahoma and now his son is uh
his grandson is governor so i just i get
i just want to work my tail off and make
sure i leave my state uh the best
the best possible state it can be when i
come back to the private sector
you couldn't give me anything other than
the kids so just all right so you're in
a pretty functioning state that seems
seems like things are going pretty well
the woke stuff's not getting in you got
business you got natural resources and
all of those things was there anything
when you came in as a businessman to
learn how government operates and look
at budgets and the way they spend and
all that stuff were you just pulling
your hair out i'm trying to get
something here that might have
frustrated you along the way well i mean
i don't really want my legislature to
see this but you know working with the
legislature has been difficult uh you
know number one i'm trying to get school
choice done across the finish line i
think that's the issue that would uh
turn our state around we want to empower
parents
not just the zip code that a kid has to
happen to be born in or living at this
time and i tell people all the time
school choice should not be for the rich
it should be for everyone and these are
these are
kids in oklahoma
and there's 700 000 kids let's make sure
we educate them and we give them the
best opportunity we put parents back in
charge so trying to get that across the
finish line is a goal of mine if i'm
fortunate what kind of pushback do you
get on that because i would imagine in a
red state i mean there's so much
momentum behind that right now i can't
imagine it's too much right well we did
not get it across the finish line this
past session i hopefully we can next
year but really the rule folks uh that
and they're right in the fact that there
aren't a lot of the private schools but
those aren't the schools we're talking
about
a lot of it it's the inner city it's the
large school districts that are
indoctrinating the kids and and then you
have to try to you get parents that are
showing us the books that they're
teaching you can't micromanage every
single school district so let's inject
competition let parents choose where to
send their kids to school whether it's a
christian school or a catholic school or
a or a
charter school we need more of that in
our state so that that's definitely a
challenge uh to try to get to cross the
finish line for our for our state
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell